let's go to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 always great to hear what's on the
mind of people in the audience we will
go to our caller from the 864 area code
caller from 8 6 4 what's your name and
what are you calling about today hi my
name is Raymond actually I've told him
before uh obviously got asked if you
thought that it was possible that the
left have you rounded up at some point
um yeah um but uh basically I was
wondering it seems like that the country
becoming more and more vulnerable
especially with the freedom of speech
being it's being decimated right now I'm
curious do you think uh that whoo we're
headed for something big soon or
honestly I feel like jumping a lot of
movement with the world wars going on it
is getting kind of chaotic and uh yeah
uh I just I it feels like I don't know
what to expect next yeah
so they're not in what ways do you
believe that free speech is being
decimated like what specifically are you
thinking of then I have one that I also
feel like that's our biggest voice in
the world that just one on one civilians
that's taking auto voice away and with
me two buckets that seems like
censorship is in every company right now
Google YouTube Facebook you name it and
you're saying like well I I guess I'm
just trying to figure out exactly what
you mean you're talking about like what
kind of censorship is happening are you
talking about the YouTube advertiser
boycott or are you thinking about
content being removed or what are you
talking about uh it's it's a little bit
of everything but the way I look at it
there's a huge attack on independent
media right now it's anything anything
that's not mainstream media is being
like there's Washington Post ads every
other article you know like it's uh yeah
I think there's a there's sort of like a
multi-pronged attack going on right now
on media right there's Trump and his
talk
about libel lawsuits against media and
also you know this sort of designation
of fake news that he's been talking
about then we've got all the net
neutrality stuff that's going on in the
attempts to rollback Internet freedom in
that means and then you've also got this
sort of huge reallocation of money as a
result of the YouTube ad boycott and a
lot of what's been going on there so I
don't know that what I would add that I
would call it restrictions on free
speech right now although we're starting
to go in the direction of listen if
Trump could infringe on people's free
speech rights to stop critical reporting
about himself he would absolutely do it
and that's why I think we need to be
really careful right now watching that
you know it's difficult when day-to-day
you see small changes sometimes it can
be hard to realize when big things
change and that's why it's important to
keep a sort of 30,000 foot view on
what's going on and hey you know not to
take your call Raymond and turn it into
a plug but we really got to be
supporting independent media financially
so that we're able to defend ourselves
like we're dealing with from bogus
copyright claims and all sorts of stuff
so I share your concerns my friend all
right what we have a good one keep it up
all right thanks very much always good
to hear from Raymond